[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants qui n'a pas été sage
moi ou non moi j'étais traça aussi je
descends voir mais n d'accord nounours
ont échoué
à l'eau sur la terre je suis bien au
fait de mordre les patrons
[Musique]
nicolas ou
machine à écrire enfin les neuf lui
devrait les enfants elle est acquis
mon petit doigt me dit qu'elle est à
papa
c'est gentil ça
serait juste les enfants alors je
tape à la machine
nicolas tu ne fais que des eaux regarde
oé oé oé oé oé
c'est la seule lettre i koné est pas
marianne
j'ai commencé tu peux continuer notre à
moi
char cornichons
nous arriverons en avion
c'est vrai pardon en nuage
de voir ces merveilleux je tape de plus
en plus ou
au
mal
ce n'est qu'un petit accroc
il serait content papa s'il voyait ça
mais ne nous énervons pas je recommence
la lettre
o on m'appelle
voilà j'avais pas trop je crois que ça
vaut mieux pour la machine de papa elle
allait de la corniche à la nous verrons
demain laissons cette machine à écrire
se reposer à long ou les
bourses tu devrais prendre des cours par
correspondance
ennui mauvais secrétaire bonne nuit gros
gris bouillère plaisanté rira bien qui
rira
bonne nuit
d'ornement
[Musique]
hall on our dépêche toi voilà voilà ne
vous énervez pas patron savez vous taper
à la machine
moi non vous devriez apprendre c'est
bien utile à notre époque allons en
route gro farseth
donniez des enfants fêtes de bourg
[Musique]
o
oh